who is Santos let me spell it for you t
is for tesseract because in space-time
beaches for him you'll see here a is for
ether it's anything at all all part of
Thanos theory it is for necklace not a
commode who o is for orb
really s is for Loki's scepter it's a
film theory hello internet welcome to
film theory the show that's willing to
take the eight-hour bullet that is
watching Marvel's and humans so you
don't have to today I'm gonna be digging
into one of the most burning questions
leading up to Avengers infinity war
where is the soul stone the sixth and
final Infinity stone and there were a
ton of expectations that it was gonna
appear in black panther seeing as hell
that was the last film in the franchise
before infinity war but then the movie
came out and nothing as black panthers
director Ryan Coogler put it I love that
finished on as much as any comic book
fan
it's just what kind of common hazards
are already hazards Dean which is
vibranium for us that without was
special enough so sort of throwing
something like another special thing it
didn't didn't feel right so where is
this thing hiding well I don't know what
all the internet hoop was about because
here's the thing we've already seen it
it is literally hiding in plain sight so
here's your spoiler alert for the whole
of the MCU as today we're gonna weave
through the massive plot of the eighteen
movie ten television show Marvel
Universe if I'm the real answer to where
this glowing piece of radical rock has
been hiding all along before creation
itself there were sixteen you know in
school you have mnemonic devices like
please excuse my dear Aunt Sally where
each letter is there to help you
remember the proper order of operations
parentheses exponents multiplication
division addition subtraction well if
you'll want to impress your friends as
you walk into infinity war later this
week the locations of the Infinity
stones function largely the same way all
you need to remember is that us just
like the spongebob song I sang at the
beginning of the episode because each
one corresponds with a letter in Thanos
is named t is for tesseract which hides
the blue space stone as confirmed by the
infinity war trailers we know Loki has
it stealing it away from the Treasury of
as guard at the end of thor ragnarok h
well I'm gonna get to that one later
hey is for a thir which honestly means
nothing to you if you skipped over Thor
the dark world and uh who can blame you
for that one Thor the dark world
literally cured me of insomnia I was
having a couple months back so put that
one on your Google Play review score
basically the aether is just a bunch of
raspberry jelly sandwich between two
rocks with the superpower of making the
final battle really difficult to see
since Asgard already had the tesseract
at the end of dark world they were
totally like yeah thanks but no thanks
guys but we already got one of these
ultra powerful stones so instead they
hand it off to this guy the collector at
the end of the movie and during Thor's
awkward bath time in the middle of age
of Ultron we see the raspberry jam
solidify into the red reality stone and
is for necklace which refers to the eye
of agamotto dr. Strange's time
controlling amulet which fittingly
enough contains the green time stone but
as far as I'm concerned it might as well
be called the retcon stone am i right
get it because once you can reverse time
literally nothing has consequences up
top okay no one no one's giving me a
high five it's alright it's alright
anyway the O in Thanos stands for warm
the quest item from guardians of the
galaxy that hid the purple power stone
the stone that destroyed the collectors
Museum and wound up in possession of the
Nova Corps at the end of that movie but
he's not and I'm quoting him here 100%
and lastly as if the cast of Thor didn't
have enough access to ultra powerful
space rocks s is perceptor specifically
the scepter used by Loki throughout the
first Avengers movie to control people's
thoughts and actions
age of Ultron reveals that inside of
that glowing blue gem was surprise
surprise a glowing yellow gem the yellow
mine stone it was like a kinder egg
surprise opening YouTube video but done
on a billion dollar scale anyway Ultron
puts the mine stone into the still
developing vision where it still sits
for now
now obviously I'm just telling you this
theory because it's more fun than it is
serious doing things like reducing the
eye of agamotto to being called a
necklace is just trying to shoehorn the
letters into the right places to come up
with a cool acronym I mean guys I just
came up with the next really cool theory
about this you're ready to cover this
one screen rant I present to you the
breast theory ball rod eye a sovereign
tesseract somehow I don't think the
breast Theory is gonna be quite as
popular as the Panos one anyway the fun
thing about the fan o's theory is that
as you can see I left out H and honestly
after reading online theories and doing
my own research the most likely place to
find the soulstone both relate to the
letter H either heimdal or him yes there
are plenty of theories circulating
around online for everything from tony
stark himself being the soul stone to
this orange-tinted planet we see in the
trailers for infinity war being a world
inside of the soul stone but here's the
thing from an evidentiary standpoint
heimdäl and him are the only two
theories with substantial enough backing
to be considered plausible so let me
first go through the heimdal theory
because personally it's my favorite of
the bunch and the one that I'm rooting
for to happen and then I'll cover the
him theory which honestly seems very
clearly where this whole Soul Train is
headed for one thing we know for sure is
that the soul stone is colored orange we
see as much in the collectors screen
when he's describing the Infinity stones
to the guardians of the galaxy and
throughout the Marvel Cinematic Universe
when a character gets exposed to an
infinity stone their eyes glow in that
color grown in the accuser and guardians
purple eyes only after he gets the Power
Stone Hawkeye getting possessed by the
mine stone in Avengers blue eyes but
remember that was back when the mine
stone was still blue even the aether in
Thor the dark world makes the eyes of
both Jane Foster and Malekith deep red
so just so happens to have himself some
orange eyes Heimdall the all-seeing all
hearing guard of the Bifrost bridge and
it's not just that his eyes are orange
but his eyes also get a fair amount of
screen time dramatic close-ups scenes in
which he's giving sight to others and
probably most suspicious of all Thor's
vision in age of Ultron where he
actually sees the other five stones
Heimdall in this scene blind his orange
eyes have disappeared perhaps the
soulstone has been removed from his body
and thereby leaving him sightless
heimdal even explicitly says in Thor 2
that he can true souls with her stone
related or not Heimdall just naturally
has a connection with soul it's not to
mention when Heimdall first appeared in
Thor he was wearing a suit of armor with
an orange stone in its chest and with
idris elba Heimdall's actor going on
record to say that he wants a bigger
part in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
having his character be in possession of
the last and most mysterious infinity
stone would be a great excuse to bring
him more into the spotlight or
alternatively if it's hidden inside of
Heimdall he'll him off and bring back
Elba as someone else so honestly that's
my personal favorite theory because it
follows the rules of Chekhov's gun
someone or something that's already been
introduced into the series contains this
magical MacGuffin but here's why it
probably won't happen if Heimdall truly
has the stone that would now make it
four stones out of six that had been in
the hands of as Guardians
and it would make it the second stone
out of six where it's actually inside of
one of the characters we also know based
on the end credits scene of Thor
Ragnarok and the trailers for Avengers
infinity war that Thanos catches up to
the Asgardian ship where he takes the
tesseract from Loki we see him add the
blue gem to his gauntlet but then who
else is on that ship none other than
Heimdall and with Thanos having a
natural connection to the stones it
would be odd for him to get one and not
the other just not a very efficient trip
plus we get plenty of close-ups of
Thanos as Infinity Gauntlet and it only
has a couple stones unless of course the
trailers have been CGI altered to hide
that Thanos has the stone in his
gauntlet already like they hid Thor's
missing eye and Ragnarok but yeah I
don't really think that's the case here
because like I said we've seen the soul
stone already so this whole big mystery
feels kind of moot the soul stone is
here it's the glowing rock at the top of
this birthing pod at the end of
guardians the galaxy - I don't know why
none of the other online theories have
talked about this thing you notice how
it's slightly bigger than all the other
infinity gems just like the gauntlet
space for the soul stone it's even
glowing a yellow orange which totally
fits the color and if you're wondering
about color and whether that's yellow or
orange Thor's vision and age of Ultron
actually makes the mine stone look to be
more or
than it is yellow so color correction on
these two stones is a bit wacky right
now I think I shall call him Adam now if
you're not a hardcore comics fan you
could be forgiven for not knowing the
bizarre story of Adam warlock savior of
counter-earth and ultimately half the
universe in the earth-616 timeline which
is the primary Marvel Comics timeline
Adam warlock was originally created by a
secret group of human scientists on
earth called the Enclave back then
Adam simply called himself him see
that's where that H in Thanos comes back
when he rebels against his creators the
cosmic entity known as the High
Evolutionary gives him the soul gem in
Avengers annual number seven Thanos
becomes the first to use the six
Infinity gems in unison he's only able
to be stopped by the collective forces
of the Avengers Adam warlock and Captain
Marvel who wouldn't you know it was
recently revealed and who happens to
have a movie smack-dab in the middle
between infinity War part 1 and infinity
War part 2 but Adams connection with the
soul stone isn't just in one comic
series I mean sure in the earth-616
universe warlock is often seen as one of
the few beings powerful enough to stand
up to Thanos so it makes sense that he
would appear in the MCU to stop him in
Avengers 4 but the soul gem Adam warlock
connection spans across all the
alternate universes in the Marvel
Animated universe the guardians of the
galaxy cartoon reveals the soul stone is
with Adam warlock his gems getting tired
in the alternate reality of Earth 911
911 is in Adam warlocks possession and
on and on the two are practically
inseparable
so inseparable in fact that when you
look at the list of characters who've
actually used the soul stone there's not
a whole lot of other ones who've touched
the thing there's Thanos there's Adam
warlock there's Doctor Strange and
that's really about all the names that
you would recognize who currently exist
in the MCU well all except for one other
nebula two angry blueberry from
guardians of the galaxy Thanos his
adopted daughter and gomorrah's adopted
sister yep of all the characters in this
extended universe she's the other person
to ever be considered a previous owner
and here's why that's interesting
guardians of the galaxy vol two's plot
begins with the Guardians destroying a
giant monster in exchange for nebula
who's been captured by the sovereign but
what was nebula doing there on the
planet in the first place
we're told that she's been caught our
soldiers have pretended her attempting
to steal the back-trace and sure we're
told throughout the movie that these
batteries are value B won't take them
batteries they're worth water quarter
mil on the open market and that they're
powerful the batteries they are
exceptionally combustible and could
destroy the entire fleet but nebula as a
character isn't driven by money she's
driven by revenge that's a child my
father would have Gamora and me battle
one another in training every time my
sister prevailed
my father would replace a piece of me
with machinery so after I murder my
sister I will buy a warship with every
conceivable instrument of death I will
hunt my father like a dog and I will
tear him apart slowly piece by piece she
isn't out for fortune she is actively
trying to kill Thanos and the best way
to do that would be with an infinity
stone the last infinity stone the soul
stone that she knows happens to be on
the sovereign planet and that winds up
powering the Adam warlock rebirthing
chamber at the beginning of the movie
clearly the Infinity stones are on
nebulas mine you hate me you left me
there well you stole that stone for your
stuff and yet here you stand a hero this
line might be easy enough to write off
as a simple reference to the first film
but even still it feels out of place if
you really stop and think about it this
line reveals what nebulous thought
process could be here
step one steal the soul stone step two
kill your family step three prophets now
I can hear some of your vulture cosplay
feathers ruffling already because Adam
isn't officially slated to appear until
guardians the galaxy 3 and MCU head
honcho Kevin Feige officially claimed
that Adam won't be in the Avengers
movies but remember he also claimed that
Captain Marvel wouldn't be an infinity
war and let's just see what the Russo
brothers have to say about that one and
we have some great female characters in
this Captain Marvel is in it Black Widow
aah Scarlet Witch honestly we have to
accept that sometimes studio executives
are trying their best to hide cool
surprises so that it doesn't ruin things
for the audience hiding a big reveal
like the location of the last infinity
stone and the one character most likely
to stop
thanos makes perfect sense if you're in
his shoes here's the thing they're gonna
be more than 60 characters in infinity
war and Thanos is gonna have to go from
zero Infinity stones to at least three
from this clip we can tell that Thanos
will start by acquiring the power stone
then move on to acquiring the space
stone right now neither of those stones
are anywhere near earth with the power
stone being guarded by the Nova Corps
and the space stone being in Loki's
possession in the tesseract a leaked
scene also lets us know that Thanos goes
looking for the reality stone and that
the collector claims to have sold it we
can also assume that Thanos doesn't have
the red reality stone when he gets to
earth as evidenced in this shot when
Captain America incredibly stops Thanos
his gauntlet that means that by the time
he leaves Wakanda at best Thanos will
have the power stone space stone and
mine stone ripped free from visions head
and then maybe he goes to search for the
red reality stone this means that it's
gonna take fan OHS about one movie to
collect at least three and maybe four
Infinity stones and that's already a ton
of stuff to cram into the space of one
movie with another Avengers movie coming
out just around the corner it would make
perfect sense that the next movie would
sent around his quest for the rest of
the stones so there you have it the soul
stone in my humble opinion should be
kept within Heimdall but it's probably
more likely in Adam warlock
either way we probably won't get a good
look at the soul stone at all until
Avengers four I also wouldn't be
surprised if it didn't show up at all in
either infinity war movie with it being
the primary MacGuffin for phase four of
Marvel or who knows Marvel might just
pull a Star Wars and half Thanos throw
the completed Infinity Gauntlet off a
cliff but hey that's just a theory a
film theory and if you're like me and
you're bummed out that you won't get to
see a soul stone for another two movies
take consolation on YouTube and the
former lots of videos about shiny rocks
now I've talked about this before but
I've had a fascination with shiny gems
crystals and rocks that probably have
magical powers for as long as I can
remember so when I'm not theorizing
about Infinity stones I still love
learning about their real-world
equivalents on the internet and my
favorite channel for gemology research
is JT v JT B's run by Natalie a
real-life gemologist who asked if I
wanted to collab for an infinity stone
themed episode
was totally like yes because she's an
amazing resource for any kind of
research related to gems in your
favorite movies and TV shows like for
instance today what stones would you
need to buy if you wanted to own your
own set of real world infinity gems she
does two videos like this a week where
she analyzes all kinds of rocks minerals
and metals from movies TV shows or
around the world and she comes to some
pretty mind-blowing conclusions about
them it's not like theories but around a
very specific type of science so if
you're into gemology mythical stones are
simply rocking out head over to her
channel by clicking the Box you see on
screen and given or subscribe if you
especially like this theory that you'll
be really into her video comparing
Infinity stones to real world gems or if
you're feeling a bit more nostalgic then
check out our three part series on
Steven universe gemstones so seriously
get your sparkle on and go show a fellow
youtuber some support diamonds aren't a
girl's best friend subscribers are